the Supreme Court will hear arguments
today in a major test of abortion rights
this morning protesters are already
outside the court for this high-stakes
hearing now this is a first major
abortion case for the courts new
conservative majority featuring two
justices chosen by President Trump Jen
Crawford outside there's been court now
with more on the story Jan good morning
to you what's at stake in today's case
well good morning Yael I mean as you can
see from the crowds people on both sides
of this issue see a lot at stake
abortion opponents hope this new more
conservative Supreme Court of start
rethinking decisions that they've
opposed for decades and supporters of
abortion rights are afraid that is
exactly what's going to happen when the
justices announced their last abortion
decision supporters of abortion rights
cheered their victory may be short-lived
it's totally possible that we would have
to close Kathleen Pittman is
administrator of Hope Medical Group for
women the Shreveport Louisiana clinic at
the center of the next major battle over
abortion rights you're required to have
a doctor session MS clinic is
challenging a Louisiana law that
tightens regulations and says doctors
must have admitting privileges at a
local hospital what would happen if the
court were to rule that the law could
stand it would be devastating
devastating not just for the people in
our area but statewide and I think there
would be national repercussions as well
more than a dozen other states has
similar laws many passed after the
arrest of Pennsylvania abortion doctor
Kermit Gosnell who was convicted in the
death of a patient and murder of three
infants abortion opponents like march
for life president jeanne Mancini say
these laws are necessary to better
protect women's health portion clinics
say that it's unnecessary because
abortion is a safe procedure
what other procedure do we know that's
done at an outpatient facility that
doesn't have admitting privileges it's
giving abortion to pass but in 2016 the
Supreme Court rejected that argument
striking down and all
identical law from Texas the five to
three decision turned on the vote of
Justice Anthony Kennedy who sided with
liberals Mancini says the situation in
Louisiana is different there are
real-life instances of substandard care
in Louisiana and there have been more
problems with the abortion clinics in
Louisiana and in 2018 just as Brett
Kavanaugh replaced Kennedy giving
abortion opponents hope that this new
Supreme Court may see this case
differently
something abortion rights supporters
fear the point of the lowest to make it
more difficult for clinics to function
and to remain open without a doubt now
according to one study Louisiana has
passed nearly 90 bills restricting
access to abortions since Roe vs. Wade
that is more than any other state and if
the court
size with rules that Louisiana's law
here can stand that could encourage more
restrictions in other states Tony all
right Jan thank you very much